amy roloff and chris merrick are married
but i have a big and special surprise
i'm planning on proposing
the little people big world star tied
the knot on saturday the newlyweds
announced their engagement in september
2019. according to people magazine the
pair were surrounded by 146 guests
including amy's kids grandkids their
extended family and closest friends
marriage to me is very very important i
mean even though i'm divorced i i still
value and will hold up high
the whole
concept the reason the purpose
that marriage is here and if by chance i
get to you know do that again
i would still put everything that i can
as best i can
you know to make it work amy shared
these photos to instagram the day before
the wedding she wrote
i'm so thrilled and excited to be his
wife if marriage is meant to happen for
me again the second time then i would
sing hallelujah amy was previously
married to matt roloff they divorced in
2016 after nearly 30 years of marriage
they share four children jeremy zach
molly and jacob yeah a lot of family
time yeah my mom's getting married in
august here zach teased the big day for
e.t earlier this summer i love it will
that wedding be televised have they
decided yet
i think so yeah i think um stay tuned
yeah stay tuned with your friends
everyone's pretty excited for it i know
because we've all been there every step
of the way it's like okay we gotta we
gotta see the actual wedding now yeah i
think everyone's pretty excited about
that stuff
yeah it's gonna be fun how great will it
be to have the whole family together to
to celebrate such a joyous occasion uh
yeah no it'll be great having the whole
family my sister doesn't live in town
neither does my brother my youngest
brother um so yeah everyone will be
coming back into the fold um
and yeah weddings are just fun you see
family like my mom a lot of my mom's
family don't live here yeah so you'll be
seeing here's his family yeah never met
chris's side of things family friends
really so
um and this is chris's first wedding too
like this is his
you know so you know it's gonna be
exciting for him like this is his first
experience
getting married um so yeah it's just
gonna be fun i think all around will the
kids be involved i could see little lila
being like a flower girl
maybe
yeah i was the same you might be like
you might see more of that you gotta
tune in
i feel like jackson's going to turn it
into his own thing
honestly though it's going to be yeah
we're going to reign it in like this is
mimi's day
him and his cousin ember yeah they both
i feel like are gonna
do some stuff everyone is here for me
yeah
they're gonna do anything they're just
stealing that day